the presumptive Democratic nominee Joe
Biden is expected to respond this
morning to an allegation of sexual
assault stemming from the early 1990s
his accuser says that Joe Biden
assaulted her when she worked for his US
Senate office senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is in
Washington with more on this story
Catherine what his team Biden saying
about this about about all of this now
well Gail good morning a spokesperson
for Joe Biden's presidential campaign
called the claim quote untrue and said
the alleged sexual assault quote
absolutely did not happen in a short
time from now we expect to hear directly
from Biden about those claims despite
mounting pressure Joe Biden did not
address the controversy in an Instagram
live chat Thursday but a former Senate
staffer who worked for him nearly 30
years ago has been speaking out claiming
Biden sexually assaulted and belittled
her he said pointed his finger and said
you're nothing to me nothing in 1993
Tara Reed worked in then-senator Joe
Biden's office she says the supervisor
asked her to deliver Biden his gym bag
and he assaulted her in a Capitol Hill
hallway and his fingers penetrating me
as he was trying to kiss me Reid's
allegations have expanded over time last
year she told a northern California
newspaper that Biden quote used to put
his hand on my shoulder and run his
finger out my neck I would just kind of
freeze however she didn't tell reporters
about the alleged assault until this
March Reed a self-described lifelong
Democrat says she did speak with her
supervisors in senator Biden's office at
the time about alleged sexual harassment
from the senator and then faced
retaliation and changed the trajectory
of my whole career in life and I lost my
job after I complained and I was fired
but two former Biden Senate staffers
reclaimed she spoke to told us they had
no recollection of any complaint Reid
has spoken to CBS News multiple times
the past month and on Wednesday CBS
formally requested an on-camera
interview a former neighbor Linda Lucas
told us read did recount the alleged
assault in the mid-90s and appeared
upset Reid's brother Colin Moulton also
backed her story to CBS News but
speaking to other outlets Moulton did
not initially described the incident as
a sexual assault on Thursday House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi defended the likely
Democratic nominee I have a great
comfort level with the the situation as
I see it with all the respect in the
world for any woman who comes forward
but all the highest regard for Joe Biden
recess she did not go to the police back
in 1993 and she does not have a copy of
the complaint she says she made
Republicans are now calling on the
former vice president to unseal his
Senate records in his home state at the
University of Delaware
Anthony Catherine thank you